I became involved with conservation work
and through that dr. Wilson's
biodiversity foundation which are I am
on the board of because it was clear to
me that that mankind human activity was
degrading our earth's resources at an
alarmingly rapid rate and that we were
losing species right and left important
species perhaps in some cases we knew in
other cases we hadn't yet full knowledge
of a species or an organism before it
was lost it's my understanding that that
much of much of our medicine much of our
food stuff that may be required in the
in the future will come from these
reserves of biodiversity which are
rapidly disappearing and unless we have
fully protected
bio systems we will not will lose the
potential to learn how nature works and
that information may be critical in our
understanding of how to manipulate what
is in our power to manipulate to to save
biodiversity save the power of our
planet to sustain life